i don't know why but i think bowling is
like the most depressing activity out of
all of the activities
really i think so i feel like bowling
with alcohol
is fun it's fine but bowling without
alcohol is
boring i think i feel like i like
bowling because
i don't didn't really play it growing up
yeah like i know like this
it's it's you're either the kid who
[ __ ] used to bowl all the freaking
time for fun
or you were that one kid who would only
ever bowl like balls for fun
a lot of people do in the uk apparently
do they yeah
why do you think bowling's depressing i
don't know there's an
air to it they're always it just doesn't
hit different
okay so i went i went okay this isn't an
exclusive incident a lot of the places
are like this but i'm just giving this
for an example
i went to a place in california right
very nice area of california
and somehow in california this place
that was very like seemed very normal
there's just this one place and somehow
this
bowling place was the only place that
gave me mega redneck vibes
and i went in there and it was very much
just like like that but but it seemed
like there was just a bunch of people
who you know like i don't know
have you been bowling in japan though uh
no i haven't well then maybe it might
change right
unless there's like screens and shit's
[ __ ] like flashlight
you gotta stir like a took a 10. like a
guy comes over congratulates you unless
that happens no way no way no
i mean how can bowling be any [ __ ]
different in japan to like other
countries i mean there's no rednecks
because to me it just sounds like the
you said it was the air about it yeah
yeah
but then this whole okay other kind of
like bowling places for some reason
universally are like the most like
semi-run-down
places out of any of like the
entertainment things i don't know why
bowling's always like places always look
the worst
i mean they're always the cheapest you
know what i mean does anyone understand
what i mean but
like but the difference is that like a
lot of bowling alleys in japan
are run by like round ones yeah so
they'll usually have like the first like
usually with like a lot of big round
ones which is like a huge arcade uh
chain if you don't know but it's like
you know the first like three floors are
like the arcades and the rhythm games
and then the next like four floors are
all the balls i mean to me it's just
like an activity to do when you're
drinking
i enjoy it but i it's i do think it's
the worst activity out of the bunch
why why because there's plenty of time
to talk to your mates you just
throw a ball every few minutes and you
get to laugh at your mate being [ __ ]
bowlers either like everyone's
too invested in the bowling and then
we're not talking right or nobody's
invested in the bowling and
what the moment that's not the kind of
people going
tell me the perfect level of bowling
ratio to conversation ratio i should be
expecting
because what happens is and and this
happens every single time you got
bowling right
everyone's talking oh it's my turn but i
was in the middle of a fun conversation
i don't really want balls you just
[ __ ] throw a like a met bowl yeah
because you're already 10 points down
you're not gonna win this one
you're not gonna get a strike let's be
realistic because you're kind of [ __ ] at
bowling right
and you know then someone or sometimes
you okay so then
sorry i'm losing my if i'm getting
tilted over bowling
so then you go up you miss out on the
conversation and it just feels like
you're like speed dating
but the one person is not getting a date
who keeps going out
right the rest but i get that if it's if
you're only going bowling with your date
right if there's only two people it's
just mate this is mates
you're in a group and then you leave the
conversation and then no one's really
giving a [ __ ] about the bowling because
having a conversation
it's just like a background activity
yeah what's the point don't do something
else well that's that's
exactly the same as like dumb yeah
that's all i have to say is exactly like
darts or pool nah darts
you can keep talking while you're
playing darts you keep talking while
you're bombing
like what you're gonna do follow him up
to the ball
what are you gonna do follow him up to
the thing like okay okay keep going oh
nice
nice ball let's go back now let's go
talk okay yeah i do that sometimes [ __ ]
off
i would be like [ __ ] off joey i'm trying
to bowl here don't do it
okay that doesn't make sense because
you're like i don't give a [ __ ] about
the bowling i only care about the
conversation right i'm bowling and give
a [ __ ] about the bowler
right and then when i'm talking when
it's someone else's turn i give a [ __ ]
about talking you're the most
difficult [ __ ] bowler i just feel
like it's a dichotomy
and it shouldn't exist there's like so
many activities i can think of that you
know no they're easier paul while you're
doing the pool you can talk while you're
doing darts you can talk
everything else you can do with that
because it's like a group activity
because we're pulling
darts i feel like it's just like two
people that's doing it yeah but you can
do it with like group
like pool you can all sit around the
table and yeah and enjoy it but there's
only two people playing pool right yeah
but okay with bowling you know like tag
because it's such a distance one too
much walking
bowling can i just put that out there
too much water
you have to walk far enough away where
you can't be in the car okay this is
going to sound so [ __ ] dumb all of
this sounds dumb i realize but you have
to walk far enough away where you are
then
leaving the conversation right here but
you don't have to leave the comments so
you are you're laughing you're concerned
if the conversation is like how you're
not going to be [ __ ] far away for
like
five minutes you're up there for like
three seconds that's enough to leave the
conference i'll be honest i've never
thought this deeply about that
it's totally about everything in my life
except for music and story
so in your mind are you are you thinking
like this could be optimized
this situation could be optimized this
isn't this isn't speed running fun
you know this this is this is fun with
extra steps
there's too much gap between no one
needs that much run-up when they're
bowling and if you do something's wrong
with you
let's shorten the distance between where
the seats are yeah
and where the alley starts well then but
i mean you're not gonna have a [ __ ]
500 meter run up the ball
right i know some people who are like i
need the full length well then i don't
want to go bowling with people like that
that just sounds like a douche
you're taking this bowling [ __ ] way too
seriously i just think that bowling is
a not very optimized sport for
friendship engagement
i'm going to put it out there i just
think it's not the best i you know what
can i say gentlemen i mean i don't know
i've had like
like because okay because i've been
bowling with like i'm sure like some
people out there that are like
connor knows what he's talking about
he's not monkey brain yeah well they're
the
people i don't want to go bowling with
because i don't know there's always
going to be those comments because
they're going to be like oh i'm not
alone i need to speak up finally
also bowling feels like an activity
where i shouldn't have to change my
shoes you know what i mean it's it's
that level of
activity that isn't serious enough to
warrant me changing clothes
the shoes part is kind of [ __ ] like
it's not like you're going rock climbing
or something right like where it's like
i understand i need to bring
like you know flexible clothing right
yeah it feels like an activity that
shouldn't require me changing clothes
and i hate the fact that
you always get the most disgusting
rancid shoes
that feel so yeah okay sure they [ __ ]
spray it they give it a little alcohol
like that does [ __ ] anything this
[ __ ] is disgusting okay to be fair
though japan is really good right with
their cleanliness and stuff like that
i've never gotten i've had that in
australia i don't want to [ __ ]
wear my [ __ ] where's waldo shoes
while i'm talking to my friends
eating the most pathetic fries in
existence that have been half cooked
while we have a half good conversation
and overpriced alcohol
i just think bowling needs to be done
better and it's depressing as [ __ ]
i don't know why it looks like someone
said childhood or trouble
bowling alley who hurt you i just show
him show me on the doorway
okay show me on the door while bowling
show me
show me on the ball no no no no no no no
no no no no no because my closing
statement on board
okay i there's a question i need to ask
you okay because have you had
bad bowling experiences when you were a
kid or is it something that you deserve
something i don't know
yeah as i become an adult this became a
thing okay because but now that i
have that thought now where i was like
you know what i just realized because
bowling places always had arcades right
yeah
i had more fun in the arcade whenever i
went bowling
so what does that say about bowling
right because you know when you when
there was like if you would have a party
with like 12 kids
yo you're waiting a long time i feel i
feel like you don't enjoy bowling for
the same reason you skip
stories it's because there's there's
like the game play like like
if you could just bowl 10 10 ten balls
in a row
and just like and there you go yeah yeah
i'm sure you would enjoy it there yeah
yeah but you're just like
scared i think i thought i skipped the
other place
i think because it's like i don't know
if you'll like this but
when it's like not my turn i have like a
tiny bit of anxiety of like
[ __ ] when's it gonna be my turn i don't
know it's gonna be my turn what am i
gonna get called out i don't want to be
that hard oh that's serious no i know it
isn't but this is the thing
someone's not really throwing balls
somewhere someone out there viewing
like experiences where you're just like
yeah it's kind of anxious just not
knowing what i'm gonna have to [ __ ]
stand up and throw something
like i just like to know that okay i'm
gonna just do it and then i can come
back
you're treating it like it's a [ __ ]
quick time event like you can go
i just want to talk to my homies or play
the arcades cause we separate them
well then maybe well then maybe you'll
enjoy bowling if that's a one-player
game
by yourself i'd be like finally i get
all of those you know my best
experience bowling was wii sports that
was the best
you know why no waiting and it's 100
optimized yeah
and you had that 100 pin bolt that [ __ ]
was fun as [ __ ] i love watching youtube
videos people getting like a thousand
pins
it's just amazing it feels good well
then maybe we should do that
just wee bowling yeah he's way balling
no no because i still gotta wait for you
to do your turn
i don't like that yeah but you can skip
it if you want skip
joey's turn skip skip skip yeah i feel
like talking to you for enough times i'm
like yeah i kind of get wonky brain now
yeah it's it's starting to make sense
i'm like scientifically dissecting
how your brain is i just think because
you know like certainly pool or darts
are
constantly like talking next to each
other doesn't really [ __ ] matter when
it's my turn but bowling because it's
like all right i have to walk up and
you know why don't you walk up with them
and also you know okay i'm not going to
lie
i'm not not a big fan of having to pick
the ball i i don't
know i'm kind of sick of doing that like
because
you've been there right that one place
where you they don't have your [ __ ]
hand size it's like it's either too
[ __ ] big where it feels like
you're trying to you're trying to grab
like three [ __ ] food containers
like large or or it's like yes i want my
fingers to be crushed to death
and potentially just pull my like
dislocate my finger when i throw this
and you know because you've been to a
place like that no i haven't [ __ ] off
that's why i'm laughing because
you must have you because i feel like
i'm in a place and you're like i can't
enjoy this bowling
because none of these [ __ ] balls fit
my hand
the one thing i will say about bowling
is that no matter ball you choose
somehow it just doesn't feel right it
never feels good like like like
you you pick a ball he's like this feels
right and then you throw it like oh that
that didn't feel good
let me go for the smaller one and then
you and you throw it you're like nah
that feels too low so go for the bigger
one again and he just i don't know it
just you never get the right one
you're in a constant state of like
anxiety to be like you guys must have
gone to some [ __ ] and you know
you know they don't [ __ ] clean those
bowling balls on the inside either
okay that's all the more reason i want
to take you guys through the japanese
bowling ball because
every single thing that you guys have
been complaining about the bowling
experience i feel is completely
get rid of i feel like i'm in the middle
for this like i don't hate bowling as
much as connor but if i would like to
make us
like a tear list bowling's like good
seating yeah it's definitely the one of
the worst
yeah it's like i'm not going to say that
bowling is like an s to your experience
or anything
like it's very like a bt for me as well
[Music]
it's like the fairy tale of
entertainment sports like it's just mid
man
remember i went on a date when i first
got here and then they wanted to go to
baggage so i was like yeah sure
sure and then in the back of my head i
was like yeah i'll take it easy on you
and then i just started like [ __ ]
destroying them
and they were like oh man i guess i got
lucky we started playing darts i started
just [ __ ] crushing them and that and
i'm like yeah good know your place
i'm joking i'm joking wow that actually
beat me in darts yeah
i just i just like does the word casual
like mean anything to you like
just playing casually now bowling is a
casual player sport i don't like bowling
it's because you can't win in it maybe
that's why because i [ __ ] suck at
bowling maybe that's why i hate it